alors depuis pardonnez moi depuis trois
semaines nous voyons la face cachée de
cette crise de façon assez alarmante des
gens qui viennent donner des témoignages
à la télévision dans les journaux qu'ils
disent j'attends depuis un an deux ans
et on me dit que je vais peut-être
attendre trois quatre ans j'ai
extrêmement mal je n'arrive plus à
marcher j'attends une engin genoux etc
c'est le fameux délestage dont vote on
vous parle je le goût à ne parler
d'entrée de jeu hier la conférence de
presse en disant qu'il ya 34 pour ça une
opération sur trois au québec qu'on doit
repousser annulé il repousse son époque
un christian dubé miley de la santé est
avec nous + dubé bonsoir alors vous en
parler ouvertement
vous ne cachez pas que c'est un énorme
problème on fait face à un défi
gigantesque
ce que j'aimerais ce soir c'est
d'essayer de comprendre quelles sont les
solutions à court à moyen et à long
terme pour les gens qui attendent une
opération
on a eu le cas de cette maille cassette
cette jeune personne qui attend deux
genoux pour lui à dit peut-être 4 1 mais
si tu vaux privé fait dans deux semaines
cinquante mille dollars qu'est-ce qu'on
feint devant ça quel est votre plan
monsieur le ministre mais qu'il ya eu
plusieurs éléments d'action première
fois celui que les québécois nous
ordonner au cours des dernières semaines
réduire les cocos vite pour qu'on puisse
arrêter le délestage ça c'est la
première chose et on doit dire aux
québécois remercie parce que rappelez
vous il ya seulement deux semaines on
avait admis le sincère qui de
spécialisation kovy l'on est rendu à peu
près 1000
si je regarde montréal le sait la motive
et québécois ont répondu à l'appel
on ne paye si la pression sur le système
certaines premières jeu donc on va en
faire de moins en moins le délestage de
moins en moins qu'à céder des choses
deuxième chose deuxième bonne nouvelle
on réengage de plus en plus de personnes
qui étaient sur des listes d'attenté rno
nos propres à pau depuis deux semaines
1010 600 infirmiers infirmières
personnel du réseau de la santé sont
sortis blanc leur convalescence
est ce que c'est une con
by maison de vaccination on a quand même
vacciné plus de cent cinquante mille
personnes de notre personnel la serbie
donc les gens reviennent 1600 personnes
cen'est pas alors ça c'est la première
ou la deuxième chose la troisième chose
c'est l'utilisation de cliniques privées
bah on a depuis à peu près six mois
signé une vingtaine d'entre nous
puissent elles aussi seront on peut dire
merci à la colite ne sont que de dire ça
il y avait beaucoup de réactions
négatives la part de la population
d'être opposition à ce conseil au privé
pour aller chercher décliner on a signé
22 ans aujourd'hui dans la région de
montréal
j'aurai encore plus de délestage de
l'ordre d'à peu près 10%
si j'avais pas lu les enfants c'est une
foule de mesures comme ceux qu'on tue
qu'on parle un jour on va être capable
de retourner à la normale mais je dois
être et c'est pour ça que je suis
transparent avec la population je publie
mes classes et schaeffler tous les jours
pour que j'envoye l'amélioration qu'ils
soient encouragés quand vous pouvoir
entendre de stabiliser la situation
commencé à creuser bon on a vu un d un
tableau passé on va leur mettre avant la
coved il y avait deux cent quatre-vingts
personnes en orthopédie qui attendait
depuis plus d'un an donc bon c'est
toujours une personne de trou mais quand
même là il y en à 3846 ce revenu sur le
prix 20 secondes
les gens à qui on offre d'aller au privé
pour 25 mai elle trentaine on a plein
d'exemples des gens qui nous ont écrit
là les gens nous disent mon médecin me
dit souvent aux privés et aux 25 ou 50
mail d'ici un mois je peux tu opéré mais
au public ça peut prendre quatre à
comment on fait pour réconcilier ce
pourquoi vous prenez pas la facture
qu'ils aillent au privé puis payer
écoutez on l'apprend des jeunes jusque
là mais pour ces gens là pour michael
vous l'avez pas pris parce que à la fin
du sociaux financement pierre va se
payer sont privés mais est ce que vous
pouvez prendre tous les codes 13
aux gens puissent envoyer d'ici quelques
mois ou privés alors comme vous expliqué
monsieur roy de la première chose que de
verser m'assurer qu'on citait du 10è
notre système lorsque l'on on augmente
elle a dit cela
maintenant avec le plat qu'on a fait moi
je suis capable de signer encore
d'autres attendent avec lui on va le
faire nous dire ce qui est urgent en ce
moment on le fait puis on va en faire
encore plus parce qu aux besoins mais je
peux pas faire je vais pas vous
contredire monsieur le ministre mais les
autres pétitions ne nous dira de toutes
les façons possibles qu'il y avait des
cas très urgent qu'on ne faisait pas que
qui ne marche qu'à besoin de deux anges
c'est un cas urgent 60 ans s'étaient
comme urgent mais je vous dis les cas
urgents
on pourrait disputer chaque code
d'espèces mais moi je vous dis comme
principe les cas urgents en effet on va
signer encore plus d'entente avec le
privé pour être capable d'en faire
encore plus et on avait besoin de
stabiliser notre système et on va
continuer à le faire écouter
on est dans un sale il faut ça me fait
penser un peu aux cas de pitau de guerre
on a eu à faire d'énormes changements au
cours des derniers mois vont continuer
dé faire mais je vous le dis il ya une
amélioration et les gens vont le voir
parce qu'on va publier les statistiques
on n'a pas avantage à quelque chose on
va être excessivement transparent bon
mais je vais vous le dire pour la
dernière fois c'est pas un temps ici et
là on appuie notre collègue david
gentili qui on parle
il ya monsieur le ministre beaucoup de
corps considérés urgent en orthopédie
qui ne sont pas opérées à qui on dit
aujourd'hui j'avais chirurgie en
entrevue la semaine dernière à qui on
dit aujourd'hui je peux même plus vous
donnez d'années je ne le sais pas car je
pourrais avoir alors je compense pas de
votre faute
il ya eu la pandémie mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas ce que vous aviez fait il
ya quelques mois dire pour attirer les
infirmières dans les blocs opératoires
puis du personnel dire en double pour
six mois les salaires on va chercher des
primes extraordinaire
pour ce personnel pour regarnir les
salles d'opération passe pas les salles
qui manque c'est le personnel est gardée
si j'avais le personnel pour le faire ce
roi offrait le personnel il pose pas
vous dit la meilleure nouvelle qu'on a
eu dans les dernières semaines c'est
qu'on aurait récupéré 1600 personnes qui
étaient sur les listes de maladies qui
était relié aux convives peu importe
donc la vaccination commence à faire son
effet dans le personnel
alors donc vous le dis on va être
capable parce que c'est beau à voir le
médecin c'est beau à voir la salle mais
si j'ai pas d'infirmière pour assister
aux chirurgies ça marche pas alors le
personnel il pose pas dans les arbres
alors c'est bien vous dire d'aller dans
le privé mais ça prend des inférieurs et
si le privé auprès des infirmières
il vient de faire du maraudage pensez
pas que si elle va comme une prime
appelons-la la prime du belem pour six
sept huit mois que vous dites moi je
vais je vais signer le chèque
je vous en voyez le double de votre
salaire mesdames messieurs infirmiers
infirmières en bloc opératoire on va
faire une opération collective pour
repérer ce monde-là triple vitesse
regardez il ya une foule d'actions je
vous en donne étroite a ajouté une
quatrième solution là qu'ils vont finir
régler notre problème on a enfin aux
infirmières qui étaient aux débats qui
ont vu leur bec pendant qu'ils sont en
train de faire un bac en âge où on a
offert à 2000 infirmières de dire
arrêtez votre formation pendant une
session
on va vous donner une bourse vous allez
payer on eu 500 quelques infirmières qui
ont accepté ça ils viennent de rentrer
dans leur cage vous ajoutez tout ça oui
je vais avoir du personnel pour
supporter les chirurgie et les arbres
mais ça se fait pas en criant ciseau
alors du bo y vit un drôle mais je veux
juste vous dire qu'on a une foule
d'actions pour travailler la thur sport
ok donc prennent une mauvaise idée
c'est pas pourrez vous dit ceux qui
doivent travailler ils sont soit déjà là
soit malade ça vous semblez dire que ça
changerait pas grand chose parce qu'on
le fait pour ne pas si ça marche et à
écouter on le fait pour les préposés au
chsct
l'enjeu avec les préposés ça nous a pris
trois formes et l'infirmière ça prend
3,4 alors c'est pour ça que je vous dis
c'est pas qu'on veut pas mais il ya une
station de le faire correctement
surtout quand on voit un chirurgien dans
ça prend des années antérieures qui sont
spécialisés et qui ont l'expérience
alors vous dites quoi aux gens qui
attendent à la maison une chirurgie
orthopédique qui souffle vous leur dites
y aura pas de miracle non c'est pas ça
que je dis j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
d'empathie parce que je la connais
personnellement
on en connaît tous des gens qui sont
dans des situations dont par des mesures
voir j'ai beaucoup beaucoup d'empathie
moi ce que j'ai avec comme
responsabilités il ya quelques semaines
c'était d'avertir déjà des aides et nous
a protégés de systèmes et québécois ont
répondu première étape de la wall ag une
faute d'action que j'ai des nouvelles et
j'en ai donc on va trouver des façons
s'il faut aller encore plus dans le
privé
n'en déplaise à certains partis de
l'opposition on va le faire parce que ça
fonctionne on a déjà une amélioration de
10 12 pour ça à montréal il ya des
médecins il ya trois semaines qu'on
ancien débat assez difficile à faire
mais que tenait à faire je vous fait
entendre un petit extrait de docteur
chagnon ici dans un grand centre
hospitalier et d'un chirurgien convient
tout de suite c'est très court entre est
d'emblée le patient qu'ovide sans se
questionner c'est probablement corps et
de le traiter le patient covin mais là
est-ce que c'est correct de délester ces
gens là plus on diminue la chance de
survie d'une tonne de personnes au
détriment de gens qui ont peut-être pas
de potentiel de survie si je peux donner
un exemple personnel
ma mère est morte en septembre dans un
cfa samedi il y avait aucune question de
la transférer dans un hôpital de soins
actifs parce que ça aurait pris la place
de quelqu'un qui avait besoin de cette
classe elle ce que les médecins sur la
pointe des pieds mais ce que les
médecins soulignaient c'est que parfois
il avait l'impression qu'il y avait
peut-être un peu d'acharnement pour
certains patients qui avaient une
espérance de vie très courte alors que
on a regardé à côté il y avait des
jeunes malades qui avaient besoin de
soins surtout on vit au même débordé des
victimes qu'on voit moins le du
délestage
écoutez monsieur roy je pense qu une
chose qu on a réglé
je remercie encore de la population
c'est que il ya deux trois semaines à
1500 hospitalisation puis à peu près un
petit peu plus que 1000 de montréal il y
avait ces choix de priorisation savent
lève on devait choisir entre dacia
provident ou en deux patients on a été
capable d'éliminer cette situation
d'urgence
alors donc ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
j'espère quand on leur pose là puis
c'est pour ça qu'il faut des confirmés
avec et puis des confiné prudemment bon
levier c'est par étapes je dubé combien
de temps ça va nous prendre
collectivement pour reprendre le retard
de toute sa vie de tous ces gens qu
attends je vais pas donner d'apt tout de
suite parce que je suis encore dans la
stabilisation au public et des
alternatives des options que je vous
explique
je pense toujours difficile de faire un
plat quand on est en situation de crise
pour être capable d'être ici moi je suis
très heureux d'avoir stabilisé que
toutes nos équipes ont stabilisé la
situation
elle doit rester comme ça si quelques
semaines je pense que quand je vais
avoir additionné le personnel qui
revient tout ce qu'on a discuté depuis
quelques minutes je pense qu'on va être
en mesure de dire quand
mais ça sera pas partout pareil c'est
pas partout dans les régions c'est pas
toutes les spécialités qui sont frappés
de la même façon on est nager j'ai des
systèmes de 2 le tableau de bord qui me
donne toute cette information là je suis
capable de discuter avec doctor who pas
retenu je pense
on est capable de oui c'est bon c'est
bien vous aussi mais j'allais vous
demander un service de de parler puis
votre saoul mines et c'est tout le monde
y est extraordinaire puis je mets
absolument pas sans doute mais parler
aux présidents des fédérations d
orthopédie ce puits dit lui fait un
accord avec lui les côtes raides
résurgent le cari je parle des très
urgent je parle pas de quelqu'un qui
peut atteindre impec une douleur ça va
on comprendra qu'il est très urgent dit
lui fait envoyer moi la liez pire si
vous pouvez allonger ça parce que
collectivement ces gens n'ont payé des
impôts ces gens l'ont doit d'être
traités neige
je vous le dis j'ai beaucoup d'empathie
pour celui ci je suis certain que demain
je vais en parler avec le docteur au
pathos parce que si des situations que
je cours en europe à 240000 situation
regardez je canisy moi je vous a pas un
pour les québécois qui me regardent les
soirs j'aimerais demander aux gens
d'aller super tester parce que pour moi
la meilleure façon de continuer à
baisser nos coeurs c'est dans les deux
cas l'enjeu qu'on a c'est que déjà
qu'ils attendent une journée deux
journées trois journées sont pas sûrs si
on lit center il faut qu'ils aillent se
faire tester on va réduire le nombre de
corps rapidement si notre processus de
dépistage est mieux accepté des
québécois puis je pense pour les
prochaines nominations ouvrait la porte
je voulais pas en parler des tests
rapides qu'on a beaucoup parlé mais ça
n'aiderait pas qu on les sort des boîtes
qu'on les amène en entreprise dans les
écoles partout les femmes c'est fait
c'est fait enfin de publier on a publié
des directives au monde j'aurais tous
nos pdg ont tous les tests rapides en
autant qu'ils soient appliquées dans les
bonnes conditions
c'est réglé c'est commencer et encore
une fois comme je le fais sur des
réseaux sociaux dans les prochaines
semaines je vais publier l'utilisation
des tasses rapides ont rendez-vous ce
débat-là pas ce qui est un petit peu
inutile maintenant il ya une politique
été déposée et ont reçu et puis pour les
tests
normaux la traditionnelle et ya de la
place on a de la marge
hier j'avais vingt mille tests de fait
je crois vous êtes à l'aise il à vous
lancer à la population de goldec
optimale catcheur go go parce qu'on a eu
175 clinique on a un des meilleurs
systèmes intégrés de laboratoire pour
parer à l'ontario c'est d'ailleurs pour
ceux qui font plus de tests rapides
parce que notre système est mieux
intégré alors aujourd'hui je le demande
aux québécois
allez-vous faire très bien puis vous
allez demander au président de
l'association des orthopédistes
d'envoyer l'année je me suis engagé qui
ont le droit de se faire opérer
la prochaine fois qu'on se parle le
suroît en garde merci beaucoup pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit